[Music]
so thanks everybody I know this meetings
all about collaboration and cooperation
but I just wanted to inform the other
panels that this is in fact the better
the best one so just sort of fair
warning I'm Andrew Sarris and I'm joined
with Sascha Brown Helen toner Bart's
Ullman and Hiroshi yamakawa and our
question was would we prefer AGI to be
conscious as max sort of mentions we the
the topic of consciousness has existed
at least in the English language since
the 16th century when Rene Descartes
wrote introduced the concept in his book
on meditations and he famously wrote
that consciousness is or concho as I
guess he put it was the perception of
what passes in one's own mind and this
is closely related to the concepts of
desire and willpower
reflection subjective experience but as
I think you'll hear in this discussion
also suffering as well so and hurt so
today theories of consciousness range
from the idea that consciousness in fact
doesn't exist
two theories about consciousness that
all that exists is consciousness so
there's a wide variety of landscape if
you're interested in some of this
actually the organization that I lead
the templeton world charity foundation
has a new initiative on accelerating
research on consciousness we're actually
pitting two theories against each other
in with experimental verification so you
can go to Templeton dot world for that
in a preamble that we we sort of
discussed related to this question we
kind of circled around the issue of the
inevitability of AGI being conscious and
for the purposes of debate where we're
saying that it may not be inevitable
that such a sufficiently advanced AGI
is conscious so we can think about this
in you know more specific design sort of
engineering terms so that if
consciousness is in fact not inevitable
we could treat it as a design feature
and therefore is this a preferable
design feature or not so that's my sort
of short introduction to the panel today
I guess we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna move in sort of we're gonna skip
around a little bit so Bart you have the
microphone okay so that's good good and
then we're gonna so Hiroshi and Bart
answered yes they would prefer and then
the note team know is proximal to me so
go for it okay yeah so my view is is the
hardest issue of inevitability that you
know when we start building more complex
machines and issues that are getting
close hbi one thing they need to develop
is is internal models of other agents
truly in telling machine has some some
notion of what other machine or other
people's are thinking about and and what
gives other people intentions and and
desires so the machine needs to develop
an ability to reflect on those those
issues when when the machine starts
applying it to itself
I think consciousness sort of naturally
emerges so in my view there's also a
sort of sense that it's unavoidable to
get a conscious machine now we agreed at
the beginning of our discussion that we
we don't really like that answer so so I
had to modify that a bit so I also think
being conscious gives us allows us to
relate to each other so I wasn't
conscious of that so
but this is life itself okay okay I'll
start over again now okay so I think it
also helps us relate to other people and
and I think we actually relate better to
other people that we've other entities
that we believe to be conscious so I
actually think that helps us in allowing
aligning our bellies among each other so
that's why for an intelligent machine I
rather liked him I would like to me need
to have that notion of consciousness so
that it can align better with me and it
will actually be a positive feature even
even if we have to turn it on which I
actually believe in focused emerge but
even if we have to turn it on that's it
gets a positive feature
okay so slogan for Anthony to write up
what's the slogan also adaptive yes okay
so we're gonna okay simple question is a
simple answer is yes but not all for the
AGI because if the age eight conscious
the we can understand that AGI and we
can come easily communicate and easily
twelve so the consciousness is a profile
to the AGI but more important point is
creativity
the other pod I prefer yes
so because AGI is not just a set of
narrow AI important point is a AGI is
adapt to the new situation to very few
data
it's not hard to trade machine running
so at that time the AGI should combine
the brand Norwich and create a new
answer to the new problem so that kind
of is
in concept manipulation needs something
consciousness manipulating the did
knowledge in the brain or something like
a machine so the important point in my
answer is a creativity creative new
knowledge for its generating the it's at
the new knowledge to the issue multi
it's very important figure
so my answer yes is point is a
creativity to generate a new knowledge
we capture that so yes creativity it
maximizes creativity
ok so team no on this side so let's go
let's go first if there are some obvious
perils of vividly taking a stand on one
side of an argument where you can't find
any of the words in the debate but it
won't stop us so my thoughts on this is
that AGI is first and foremost like a
tool for solving world's contexts
challenges and doing good in the world
and making the world a better place and
that is easier to currently do with our
current knowledge if AG I can't doesn't
have the capacity for self-awareness and
suffering a it makes the task of AI the
AI safety task much simpler
second of all given the knowledge and
the data that we have on like how to
create consciousness and how to stop
suffering you're putting a possibility
out there of creating infinite suffering
I know a lot of people say that like
actually you might have infinite joy and
well-being but the evidence that that
will happen is I think currently based
on like blind faith rather than a data
that we have and third there are some
like unpleasant tasks in the world that
are going to have to be done by
intelligent beings and I prefer they
would be done by beings that aren't
conscious and are therefore suffering I
think that kind of there isn't I don't
believe it there's like a moral
imperative to give consciousness where
we can I think contraception is fine to
use in the u.s. Khan stopping
consciousness that would otherwise
appear and I think I don't know I never
want my shoes to be conscious even if I
could meet unconscious so
on to table arts point but giving AGI
some sort of consciousness would make
them more likely to kind of look on us
well I think the way that we treat lower
consciousness in our world of chickens
or whatever it might be is evidence that
perhaps you just because something's
conscious and and you're conscious
doesn't mean that you treat them in a
better way so in summary I would say
let's focus on the current consciousness
we have in the world making them better
and suffering arrest rather than adding
infinitely more in its no infinite
suffering ok all right so Helen yep yeah
I mean they think I broadly agree with
Sasha I think the definition of
consciousness that makes more sense to
me or that I think is most useful for
these purposes is to think about whether
the system has subjective experience or
in other words whether it's sort of
morally relevant in some important way
whether we care about what happens to it
and so I think you know we're if we
could just completely assume that
consciousness was out of the question
which we obviously can't but if we could
it seems like we would already have huge
issues with figuring out how do we build
systems that solve problems for us the
way we want them to that solve the right
problems
what probe you know how do we use those
systems so this is basically the
technical safety and the strategy kind
of questions that would already be
extremely difficult even if
consciousness was out of the question
and so similarly to Sasha I think adding
in consciousness and making it be the
case that we also have to pay attention
to you know how is the system doing is
it enjoying life is it having a terrible
time how should we value its experiences
relevant to our experiences whether it
be sort of one massive you know smart
city controlling system that is huge and
potentially much more you know has more
experiences than are some more important
experiences or whether it just be you
know billions of you know you could
think of like a much smarter serie you
know which is sort of maybe some seems
equivalent to a human but there are
billions of them like what do we do with
that it just seems
like a whole extra a bunch of complexity
and risk that seems way more than what
we need
especially sort of at first with the
first sort of more general purpose
systems that we build
so I guess an analogy that it is sort of
how it feels to me is we could be aiming
to build something that's kind of like a
general-purpose Google Maps where like
Google Maps it's really helpful
I ask you to question about how to get
somewhere it sort of noise or ever are
you being and where I'm likely to go and
all these kind of things and so you can
imagine a similar system that you know
as much more general could do many more
things I would love that seems really
useful still seems difficult to build
and still seems difficult to know you
know how to use it but so you have this
all-purpose general maps or you have
like this alien Butler who someone has
given to you and said hey this alien
like really wants to serve you and help
you out or like serve your your country
and help your country out like be nice
to it I guess because you don't want to
have a bad time I don't know it just
seems like the general purpose Google
Maps is like way way preferable no alien
Butler's no alien I mean you use the
concept of a before above a moral
patient yeah so you know that is an
additional consideration I think that
the team know is bringing on - I think
that's right you know if it's if it's
not inevitable if conscious if
consciousness is not inevitable in any
sufficiently advanced AGI does that does
the addition of consciousness give any
kind of additional moral consideration
that's required in its management and
its interaction and so maybe the team
yes it could I don't know a very smart
Google man and there I would agree that
you don't have to be conscious when you
think of something almost more mundane
it's like the digital personal assistant
which there's a lot of work on that if
you actually start thinking about what
you want from that assistant you
actually want that assistant to to be
able to put you know himself or herself
or itself in your shoes
actually have sort of a model of what
you would want in the world to make the
right decision so that doesn't do
something that is totally what you would
yourself would never do you and you
don't want assistant to be you know
totally different than yourself and and
I think someone that the student has to
have a model of you I think that that
the assistants has to have a sort of a
level of reflection so I'm thinking more
of those kind of entities and they can
be very smart and sophisticated to have
that without any conscious think that
feels to me actually that could be
trouble I almost see the opposite of
that would be very safe I say no that
that that entity might make might do
things that I would never do myself but
since that is so isolated from from our
world
it probably could do things that I would
never do in something that doesn't have
its own consciousness and if I had to
build a model that worked towards a
particular value might prefer to do that
then convince a very smart person to to
do something that I wanted it to do yeah
I think it's a really interesting
question this question of like would a
system with its own subjective
experience be more likely to empathize
with us and want to treat us well and I
guess I'm sort of sympathetic to the
position but it doesn't seem it doesn't
seem particularly likely to me that
consciousness helps us in this way why
is that
I like Sasha's analogy of the chickens
that you know we most humans if you
really ask them about it don't seem
confident that chickens don't have
subjective experience but we still are
not very nice to them at all and I think
even even if exactly and I think
brilliance of chickens because of human
beings desire trillions of chickens
they're absolutely appalling conditions
yeah but I think even if you forget the
chickens and say other humans I think
humans have a long history of treating
other humans terribly and to the extent
that we don't that's more the exception
than the rule so I think about the
conscious net we have to think the first
postulate for it's a
if we think simply a robot yeah we can
sink the concentrate like us some a
physical body than one conscious but
today in morning sometimes I said there
are very cruel cloud system essentially
with so where is the consciousness for
resources related to the concern that is
not envy you and if Google Maps there
are many consciousness for one month so
the relation the consciousness and
radiated where data was something with
very variable so this kind of discussion
is more flexibly we should do that sure
I mean I think I think what you're
saying is that you know be good to have
some kind of heuristic it's measurable
it could allow us to define the
boundaries of any consciousness yeah so
for aficionados of information
integrated information theory provides
such a such a kind of heuristic but
that's really not the point of the
discussion here but I think that's it's
relevant to try and identify like we're
your consciousness existing boundaries
are mistakes being so other points of
disagreement to help you know the
questions over here yeah we can take up
front first Bart your socks are taking
me to another new level of consciousness
those are I have a question about
surveillance capitalism seems to form
its own level of consciousness in this
sense of art I like how you were talking
about a personal assistant and this is
not to be negative to corporations or
surveillance per se or capitalism per se
but the choices that we make in terms of
dictated you know Eli Brizzy a filter
bubble etc seems like a personalised
assistant right now is sort of an
oxymoron in that sort of surveillance
capitalism side of things so I'm just
reflecting like that's already seems to
be a type of consciousness but it's
externalized on to the internal person
does that
any sense and you see that is something
that is a consciousness that's not s
something you'd like to pursue or it's
yes I had not fathered that kind of
conscience but I think that could be
viewed it yeah I would not find that
particularly positive because I guess
it's controlled by a government er yeah
it's a technology which would in fact
encourage the transfer of objective
awareness you know from an individual to
well that's where we live now yeah right
in terms of consumerism that that's
where we are sooo it's now but that's
not the one I'm advocating I'm man for
this personal assistant self-contained
in a private notion of consciousness so
I'm concerned that we're conflating many
aspects of consciousness in one word and
really what the no camp is talking about
is morale patient Thetas I think we can
build machines not so far in the future
very short term I wrote a paper about
such things and other people are
thinking about such things and have many
of the aspects of consciousness that we
care about that the cart was talking
about including subjective experience
and I think that's different from
suffering and moral patients ages
because humans have all of these
characteristics we tend to you know
bring them together but I think we were
just doing the wrong debate here I mean
I would I would strongly agree that it's
difficult to discuss consciousness
because we mom so many different
concepts under consciousness I would be
interested maybe I'll come and talk to
you later I'd be interested to hear
specifically that you think that
subjective experience and moral patient
hood not like absolutely connected but I
think that's probably gonna be difficult
patient status has to do with the role
of the entity in society and how we view
that entity and and what
responsibilities and duties we have with
each other whereas me detective
experience is a trivial thing that neon
that has a representation that's learned
from data already has
it's it's a personal individual
understanding of the world that's
derived from its its its data and its
interactions with the world the notion
of consciousness that has to do with
what the fleeting thoughts that's also
something that's useful maybe in a
different sense than what Bart was
talking about from a computational point
of view for a machine to have in order
to be able to focus computation where
it's relevant notion of self-awareness
is something that we need as well for
agents that are moving in the world and
they're interacting with other agents
and even emotions are things that could
be useful and and and in some form are
we there in reinforcement learning it's
just that we have very primitive notions
of these things so the the other thing
is I don't think consciousness is a
black-and-white thing are you can have
different levels of consciousness and we
think of maybe different animals having
more or less consciousness but again
it's conflating all of these notions I
think we did kind of baby about it
before but we thought we had 20 minutes
before non-expert so we would sort of
generally choose one thing I think the
consciousness is very important for if
they have to have a responsibility if
they I hit him I have to remember and
eat me
it's liek memory so another side of my
comment is in the brain campus is a very
important role for the episodic memory
it is very no out that the memories area
and it to campus has according the Aero
centric coordination and center
integrated many integers so the in the
brain the hippocampus is a very very I
think the spaghetti is a very good place
for the memory and so but so I think
that if in brain there are many Spock
campus if you have a many
idea that that something thank you or I
have to save that for cocktail hour
anyway thank you panelist for discussion
and
[Applause]
[Music]